here we go six
six four Okay Tyler Arena starting in a
few seconds
so earlier I was playing a lot of
gambits
for now I'm gonna go back to my
main openings
I'll play something a bit more solid
um okay Bishop G5
playing Grandmaster double 11.
that line of mine this is not the main
move
but it's a playable move Go Eric
thank you to something my stuff
I think this is fine first
the general plan is Knight G6 C6
foreign
yeah so there's some pressure on the
e-file like F6 might be a threat
it might not be but something white has
to
pay attention to
yeah reinforcing each seven
now F6 doesn't work
C5 is an idea
can't play it right away though
actually a little bit stuck here
and trade a bunch
um
yeah what do I do in this move
I guess ideas to play B5
still feel a bit stuck though
B5 Knight C5
yeah I'm getting squeezed
and it's not pleasant
maybe
um you take some Knight G6
I can put the bishop here and then
gradually prepare some C5 break
yeah this is still very uncomfortable
are you Rook at feeds
idea B6
preventing Knight C5
and now maybe maybe you see five the B2
hangs in the event of take six takes
like even if takes takes Rook takes I
take on B2 Knight takes I would win C5
so there's some counter play here I do
see four B5 Maybe
Connect Four
I'm allowing takes but after it takes I
think it's okay
leaving tension because I might want to
open the C file
oh there's this idea too except that
would get muted
um
it's annoying
French
foreign
positions have been unstable
that's very tense
so I'm down the pond but this Pond is
strong
am I winning
B3
might be winning this
looks really good now
I'm trading Queens
let's go
oh
Checkmate
oh what a funny finish
I was about to just Auto Queen like
thinking
that it's over but
let's go under promotes at night with
Checkmate was not expecting that
to happen
I think my heart rate got paused
it made it my heart rate may have stayed
at 88 that whole game
oh what a nice start to the tournament
okay
um I think I've only done that like what
two or three times in my life
it's all happened within the last
oh okay as another game started I didn't
realize
it's all happened within the last few
months too
I gather Rose and trophy for that
okay uh I guess I'm playing uh
foreign
of mine
it's actually a cool line never mind
to do this D3
I think A3 Bishop A2
okay this looks reasonable
there's a lot of similar Grand Prix
ideas
I can try and employ like F4
oh thank you nikox also good game night
clocks I assume
we uh yeah we had played the first game
of the warm-up Arena
I appreciate the raid
I was a player who beat me with a
wayward Queen I tried to play that funny
line
okay E5 is double edge but I think it
makes sense hit the knights
Knight d7i with a no I don't win a pawn
because Bishop C5
yeah maybe I take first
still looks good
take syncing each one
and now I'm trying to take Bishop C5
runs into B4
black has a bishop pair but it's not a
super strong Bishop pair
yeah so I'm up a pawn and probably
winning another Pawn eventually
oh thank you nyclocks as a first time
chat I didn't know you stream I know
you've played before
what tea are you drinking uh coffee
I'm drinking actually a uh it's a
pumpkin spice
oat milk latte I got these new coffee
pods recently
it's good
I've been enjoying it
keeps me awake
I saw him calculating uh Rook da takes
takes Queen a uh Queen eight there's um
Rook to you again I guess I win a pawn
though
there's another line where Bishop f8 is
played and I play and a five
so I've worked together I win the pawn
Bishop f8 okay
a pawn here
up three pawns now
some B4 idea
I think we need two first a solid before
coming soon
and now I have six people having the
heart of a teacher love the content
oh thanks so much
so Baba Benji
yeah here's just a matter of staying
calm
and maybe trapping the bishop
that's a funny Bishop trap like it's
kind of the end game and The Bishop's in
the center of the ward
but all the pawns kind of play a role in
taking away all the squares of the
bishop
okay two other two
good start to the tournament
oh thanks so much to gcook gifting to
nikox
top 30.
as a long tournament usually tolerenas
are bullets and two hours long but this
is Blitz and three hours long so
have to pace myself I'll take it one
game at a time
not berserking
yeah I'm realizing if I played Knight C3
block with a pre-move knight C6 and
could have had that trap
okay this is a line I had against um
lay later
forget her name
one of the top female players in the
world
and This Global Chess Championship
a few months ago
this line is like considered to be equal
but
um I think it's a little bit easier to
play for whites
although I should know what I'm doing
here
a castling
maybe some B4 eventually
B4 is an interesting idea
the ideas after take I play C4
seen this theme in some other other
positions
so it's kind of a Gambit
I'm not winning back the pawn
tour
I think I have to take
maybe I could go for A3 A3 though
and this could get very sharp very
quickly
wow
it's a little bit unsettling
probably take
and I'm banking on the fact that the
knight's controlling the square
foreign
I didn't have enough danger levels
so C5
how bad is this actually
because I am hitting the knights
Rook C1 could come with check
it's actually really interesting ready
to take here if the Knight moves
wow
I don't see the meat I might be getting
mated but I don't see it
oh I lose a queen
I have some material for it
I have two nights in a pond for it
that's not enough material
but it's enough not to resign
takes
96
and Bishop takes is possible Knights
pinned to the H1 Square
there's this move
threading the fork
good move
this is terrifying I'm also down a ton
of time
I'm throwing this and this
nice defend each other
foreign
take
not easy to stop actually
we can see when I Rook E1
um
I can only take one night
I'm forking the Pawns
uh
yeah I'm lagging
and getting mated
ah what to do that was a cool game
though I actually wanna
like real quick
check the
check the position
like after rookie seven
yeah rookie seven light's not losing
light still works but uh there's
actually like a cool
cool geometry Happening Here
okay back to tournaments
so two wins one loss so far
that was a fun game though
a crazy position from the opening
that's a long tournament
um
I'm gonna mix up the openings I see acts
for typo in the chat
uh so I'm gonna play a Brooklyn which is
the opening that he taught me
this is a
this is not like the best opening but
it's actually like easy to play in Blitz
you just kind of get a structure
and
um it's kind of similar to uh
like a Mainline alkyne
I'm stacking the pawn
some idea Queen C8
I like the queen here
because later I might want to trade
Bishops
the light looks out of play here but
with this setup it's hard for white
actually
punish the knights
here rookie eight
I want to play this eventually
it's H5
let's start with this
Bishop 4 Bishop D4
foreign
D3 is a Promised Land
oh my Bishop's hanging
uh
let's move back
94 might be coming
94 Knight C5
this interesting fight so far
oh thanks for the new Prime Subs
take the blue pill
forever delayed
yeah I think so earlier to people who
subbed who I didn't think
usually a tournament like this I um
I really try and
focus on the games I don't look at chat
too much
B4 might be coming I wonder B4 Knight A4
or even b4h6
yeah 93 I think was a mistake because
now this Knight is I think just trapped
a nice just trapped
there is B4 still
I should be winning a pawn though
so I'm calculating
wow
hmm
up a piece white definitely has some
compensation except
oh wow the Brookings
I think that's okay with me though
take F3
at least the pawn blocks are Rooks
like scores are a bit weak F3 happens
so I have two minor pieces for rook and
Pawn
oh G4 traffic sign Bishop
okay now it's me who's gonna be down
material searching for compensation
it's still playable though
up a little bit of time
let me close down the files
okay now that doesn't attack anything
cons defended
rather do this
thing made in one
oh no my Pawn
staring alive
about to get crazy
young children close your eyes
oh no
wow
oh
man
look at this final move
Queen G6
it's like I I aimed for the queen and
missed
I'm playing a game
I really have to be careful of having
multiple tabs open
new games start instantly
and some more time to cool down
top 100
playing the person in 99th
okay let's calm down with a London
oh that was a Brooklyn game too well
thank you Josh for
inspiring me to play such an opening
I think usually when Knight f27 is
played then C4
makes most sense
like changing from traditional London
setup to
something resembling Queen's Gambit
it should be four expected
I think it's already Pleasant for lights
a little bit behind in
development
Queen c2's multi-purpose
idea might be the castle
get the Rook to the D file but also to
play Bishop D3 you get the battery
this comes with tempo
I do have to be aware of this idea
but black has to yeah I had to do
something there
hmm
let me just play more positionally
like Knight C6 A3
I'll build up uh in the center
we might see B6 Bishop B7
you're wondering if I can get away with
B4 like B6 B4 takes and then takes
because I hit the Knight
wow F6
you guys still have to play Bishop G3
otherwise E5 could have been annoying
oh my Rook
I was relying on what I had looked at
earlier I just hung a rock there
I'm down the exchange
oops
because I was looking at B5 before the
bishop landed here
oh what to do
usually those types of things happen to
me towards the end of the tournament
just a matter of staying focused
it's still interesting though like
there's still plenty of fight left
I have the bishop here
and there's all this Pawn tension
you can win a pawn now
so Bishop D6
uh maybe take some Bishop here
foreign
oh no I'm missing everything
but I'm still not dead
and that's what matters
up almost a minute
opponent's been taking so much time
trying to figure out all my
like terrible moves
Bishop A6 is still an idea
I have a rook off of one two
one Queen three
I'll start with Moana Queen E3 Bishop G6
hitting the Rook
there is
that's a good move
and queen E2
threatening this
Rook still attacked
I keep the Knight defended as well
yeah with the time situation I just want
to keep things messy
six
hmm
foreign
oops
oh no
again young children close your eyes
oh
ah all these games is coming down to
Crazy time scrambles good game though
well played
I'm sure things were missed at some
point by both sides
what to do okay I'll berserk back
oh Queen E2
can we need to
I'd like C6
this looks interesting
I'm just losing a piece
oh no
the Tilt is setting in
how bad is this though maybe I can treat
it as a Gambit
track and Bishop C5
takes Rook g8s
I'm down the piece here about the Kings
on G3
yeah this is far from over
what a funny opening
there should be five for team one king
D7
couldn't move
a very good move
there's about five maybe coming
hey Eric I watched you playing duck
chess in the vods oh no my king should
be a merch design how about selling
themed rubber ducks quack
that would actually be cool talk merch
uh
foreign
oh man
that's three games in a row insane time
scrambles every game
oh thank you emberg I like that
suggestion I wonder how hard it would be
to
produce duck merch
okay
I've only lost two games
okay
um
I just want like a clean game where I
don't have to dirty flag my opponent
let me try and manage my time
it's not easy and look so
but getting opening preparation is
um is always a nice start
I loved the duck chess match quack
oh yeah maybe if I have energy towards
the end of this tournament
or after this tournament
then perhaps we can
have some more duck chess
excellent clutch Eric also quack Also
let's go him Rosen oh thank you
swagmaster
so this is kind of an interesting idea
that
I sometimes like to play
the pawn supported and queen also
can potentially help out
attacking the king's side
E6 wow
I'm very tempting to Castle here
long term I might want to go for like F3
G4
okay here I can take
if e takes I play E6 ooh then the Knight
is
it gets interesting
I don't know if I want to play E6 though
I'll do it
so now Bishop's pinned might be
threatening this
yeah this is leading to some trades
black has a pretty Immaculate Center
threatening this
was taking on D5 work
no I don't think so
I think Rook H3
it's about to get very positional
thinking about F4
oh actually is that four
so I forgot for I have Rook G5
King H6 Rook G3
upon that for I was thinking 92
maybe starting with this
let's start with this
we'll see this or this
I have six blocks defense of the pawn
okay now the rook's tied down to
defending the pawn
A Simple Plan of uh
getting the Rook to the G file
96 coming
so maybe I can play this
preventing 96.
preparing this
um
Esh
oh yak samas
welcome back my name is Borat
okay so I'm attacking defending
we might just be Trading
but I might also just win a pawn
because in a lot of lines like we trade
on G5 and I win H5
just like this
although wow I have to be careful of
rookie shade rookie chain I have
knighted F4
has to be okay
so here here defending there's no time
to take because I take here
okay
up on time more importantly
starting this as well
yeah I think I'm winning something here
because this is a threat this is a
threat
okay this was a much cleaner game
manage time better
okay
it'd be nice to have more games like
that where my heart rate stays below 100
the whole game
foreign
good luck to our talk we've played
before
um
forget what he plays though
I'm pretty sure we've had a similar game
in this line at some point
so what's the theory here
what's the theory
Knight C6 first
Roxy at Asics
yeah so the threat is to take and play
B5
which I think I can still do here
it's been a while since I looked at this
and I was looking very deeply at these
lines
in Abu Dhabi
oh did I already mess up
I may have already messed up what did I
do
yeah this is definitely not my prep
ah
I just lost a pawn
and rookies yeah this is really bad
I got confused
I'll just play this down the pond I
guess
some Queen B6 idea and
it's still hitting the queen
yeah the problem is white has two
connected pass Pawns
okay so okay one Queen E2
I mean the idea is to play Rook D2 which
don't think I want to do right now
still threatening Rook D2 Maybe
Queen E6
time is not good
this queen H4 just win
I have Queen C5 Chuck
okay so reinforcing the knights
some idea H5
okay pinning the pawn from behind
that's a good move
I want to play Knight D5
okay I'll be threading Queen C5 in the
end of this
I could move
foreign
okay
is that a peak heart rate for this
stream
I was really close to winning too I mean
I pre-moved 906 like hoping he was gonna
try and play Knight of six so it was a
bad pre-move on my part
what a game though man
at least I didn't lose that I was
getting completely outplayed there
that'd be interesting to like monitor
the heart rates of the people watching
and like see
if the average viewer heart rates
is higher
or lower than mine when I'm playing
these games
okay
okay Staffing cabin time
and this was just muscle memory
um
I'm gonna hold off from Sicilian for now
oh this is a fun one
I'm usually happy to see Bishop E3
because most people play King D2
Queen F4 is the best move of them
yeah so I went back material I think I
can take with a rook
man it's a weird type of trade
it was a B6 first
so we're just in some end game
um I want back upon so
can't complain with this
especially for his Stafford
94 might be coming which
it's a little bit unpleasant
thinking of playing this first
just aligning with a king
then like G4
another idea is to play Bishop here
which kind of it's just kebab's the
pieces
B6
so takes takes D4
maybe C5
I have a slightly more active King
expecting C3 or King D3
so okay it takes uh C5 C3
not sure if I'm gunning anywhere 27
months I have been taking a break from
tournament chess but I hope in a few
months I can return
and brakes can be good
I'm not sure what to do
some F5 eventually
maybe this move
I really wasn't sure what to do that's
probably not a great move I was just
seeing a lot of lines where I eventually
play this
because it does help
um it minimize White's counter play
okay so now there's an idea to take and
then run in with a king
and we could end up repeating here
let's see G3
okay it's gonna get spicy now
yeah D5 coming
I mean gotta go in
G2 can't be defended
D5 E6 I take and then oh E6 is actually
like hard to achieve
The Rook pinning the pawn
and the g-pawn is going to be pretty
quick
I see the the message from emberg
something about duck chess
it was invented in 2016 wow
I'll look at that closer in just a
moment
oh
oh no
oh I messed up
or no 37 I have rookie one
now this is all okay I think hopefully
Maybe
oh no
no
[Music]
I was probably winning there
I'm just lost my train of thought at
some point
uh was it winning
is it never winning for me no it had to
be winning
later
uh G3 immediately which makes sense but
still not winning
here
[Music]
um
King E3 and if this
okay so I had to go for this line
and then whites white has no more checks
wow
okay
what to do
top 200 tough tournaments
that's berserk we'll worry the player
still a title player
but I'll try and rebound a little bit
F6 incoming
basically G7 okay
an interesting uh
Square for the night
oh Josh's dopamine levels rise when
watching the the Stream
I guess that doesn't always correlate
with heart rate
I wonder if it's possible to have like
a dopamine monitor during during these
games
like if I lose a game do I just got
do I lose dopamine
I wonder how it works
not sure if you can monitor it in real
time though
okay this is Pleasant
because Bach is left with us
um a weak deepon
I'm still down about a minute
it's an idea to play this this and then
checkmates
and then if I would come
so preparing Bishop F3
okay King wants to be centralized
there's a typical maneuver uh 92 to F4
the Knight looks good on D4 but it it
does get in the way of The Rook
now my King's in the way of The Rook
I'm not sure how to break through
I just hung upon
that's not gonna be easy to win
or Draw like I'm worse here
time wise and never mind
that's what I needed
still takes work
foreign
there we go
those
there we go
okay
it wasn't easy I got some berserking
points
it's a long tournament that was just the
first hour
13 tournament points total
haven't really had a great streak thus
far
playing
I'm Joker
um
okay different move order
might be playable here
I think C4 actually makes sense
it's a move to try and Target this like
early setup I'm threatening this also
preparing this
you can take with pong
stick with Queen
so Knight C6 Queen H4
have the half open H file
yeah not super easy position for lack
so B5 coming
[Music]
um
that's typical when
white has a double G pawns like this
just to
push for G5
I think I can get away with this too ic2
King D2 takes and then takes Queen
defends the bishop
thank you Mr check
Roxy one
thank you mcnabbits
told the backing of the dark Square
Bishop to G3 doubling your Pawns
I was no longer preferred it really
depends on the position
very often
multiple ideas are playable
recently I've um at least in main lines
like over this 95 idea
but Bishop G3 is still a very Classic
Plan very solid
I think maybe it's time to Castle
and the battery was nice but
The Rook belongs
to
control the more Central files
in position is very pleasant now
this move comes if Queen E7 I play this
hitting the Knight and the pawn
Knight D5 I take hitting the Rook
Pawn now
Rook C4
Rook C5
yeah because now E6 was a bit tender
still this idea
wow this Rook is going full circle
or full rectangle
back to the H file
I started here when here here here
I don't think it's actually going the
full rectangle but close enough
okay if I take and then play E4
I think this move is more annoying for
black
A4 so The Rook supports a pawn
Bishop's almost trapped
I could play G6 there
would have been cool
and this also looks really nice
foreign
at night
one year sub
happy one year Adrian Jess
appreciate that
okay that was a clean game
on the street now
so this whole tournament I have not yet
won three games in a row
so let's see if I can uh
let's open the third game
that was a fun game though
okay oh no no no no no no no no no no
not B5 I wanted to
I wanted to play the Sicilian I guess
now I'm playing a little swollen
O'Sullivan Gambit time unexpected
I wanted to play the Sicilian
wait I have three is not a good move
this is one of the main O'Sullivan traps
let's go okay this worked out
beautifully
that's so great I played B5 and we just
transposed
Ah that's a good move though
I guess I'm not winning so much material
great move
take C4 and queen A6
Queen A5
I'm not sure what to play here actually
Queen E5
I'm not actually leading to a funny
position
so I'm hitting the pawn Knight's still
pinned
now I can take the pawn
I mean Knight B3 is coming
I have not moved any Center Pawns
I mean the only piece on the board that
I've moved so far is a queen
oh let's play this move
to develop something
what if I just don't move my Center
Pawns
ever
I play G5
G5 looks fun let's play it Knight takes
time mates if Queen takes I lose upon
this will play F6 but
not quite working
there's almost a really funny line let's
start with
and I start
maybe just each
H6
I want The Rook to get to the G file
H5 now
H4
H3 may be coming
actually let's play Rook G8 now
so I'm threatening to take the knights
free nights
I think white just missed it wow I won
the game without moving either Center
bomb let's go on the mouse slip oh
Sullivan
it's actually funny that you can like
upon playing B5 you can just transpose
into a no Sullivan
because white could also start by taking
and after this this this this it's no
Sullivan and this is like the mean
trappy line
um
if you want to learn more
I made a whole video about this gambits
over a year ago
I don't usually play it
it doesn't have the same
uh sort of Venom as a Stafford but
there's still some fun traps
still some funny lines as we saw
berserk okay let's play a Stafford
I insist ooh A3
maybe I could have played reverse nights
but
like this
okay so I'm winning a pawn
actually looks pretty good for black
we need seven coming
why we'll have the bishop here I'm
trying to tie down the king
hmm
I Rook D Bishop D3 Rook D4
an H5 King G7
a little bit iffy H4 might be coming
each part I have G4
which would be five I'd taken Queen F6
I think it's okay
I'll see four ideas wow what is this
what is this
click on D3 take
I just want to simplify
always play F6
oh I did not see this move but
I'm still holding on
Queen is completely stuck
not easy to trap though
okay forcing Queen trade losing back
upon
like this
wow White's just getting stuck
now King and Rook are completely stuck
Checkmate wow what a nice game
okay
on a streak
is that that's four in a row let's go
here we go
approaching the halfway points
top 80 now
playing cubicson
foreign
openings have been working well for
black or well for me I should say
no Gambit this game
I guess this is a queen's goddess no
Gambit from my side
yeah this is a quieter opening
the early trail of darks were Bishops
Knight G4
it's a weird looking move but
it prevents F4
I'll get the structure
and F4 might comment some points
actually the first game I played in this
tournament we had very similar type of
position
at least the same structure
So the plan is to double up and put the
bishop back
not sure what my plan is now
I mean B6 B6 E5 Maybe
it was interesting
it's a pawn sack
which white declines
so threatening C4
still threatening C4
lc4 there's takes
hmm
here rookie five first
and going for some Rook lift
ah there's some funny lines like Queen
here I play this Knight takes I play
this queen takes I take and then win the
queen
hmm
maybe Queen E7
it does G5 almost works well
27
trying to comprehend what's going on
and there's my C5 but Knight G2
the queen is a little bit overworked
I think the tactics are so fine and
threading this
ah when I play Rook G5 I'll also be
threatening Bishop H3
hmm
that seems like a very difficult
position for whites
okay now maybe this move
and queen G3 Rook G5 is really nice
otherwise like Queen A4 why
now Bishop D7
I could also just play C4
cutting off the queen and preparing this
threading this and this
Rook oh there's almost a funny make
foreign
I can't resist it might not work but
it's so funny
it involves hacking almost everything
I think it works I don't know though
can we have two in the end
no this is mating
is it
where's the meat
there's my mate
there we go okay
oh that was a nice game
that was like um
a bunch of different sacks
starting with
actually it was just like sagging the
rook and then stacking the bishop and
then sacking the Knight
yeah it was
I sacked Rook bishop and Knight
like back to back to back sacks
okay nice
five wins in a row
keeping this streak
regaining all the rating I lost from
earlier
playing moruga mentality
okay
we'll stick with this
yeah there was a question earlier from
McNuggets like kind of alluding to this
bishop G3 versus Alternatives Knight E5
has been my move of choice recently
but Bishop G3 is still very playable
I had this earlier against the same
opponent Maybe
this is very similar to what I had
earlier
I mean I think we're repeating the same
line
that was a game where I like played B4
and hung a rook
I can't recall though
it was a different opponent
so this might have three Waits let's
take first
this time I'm gonna play Rook C1 before
I play B4
foreign
exactly this position earlier I think it
was against someone else
do I still go for B4
uh let's play this
it Bishop B7 though
now before it doesn't have the same
punch
everybody Rook D1
is optimizing sometimes when there's
tension
it's best to leave the tension and just
optimize
the pieces
I still want to play B4
E4 is another idea
and I have three is logical
so there is an ideas of a E4 D4 E5
that weakens D4 Square
okay I'm just gonna hold my ground
try and keep improving somehow
maybe each five idea
there's also this idea
wow
so yeah the Knight wants to come to D4
now I'm setting up the potential for the
battery
so in some cases it forces black to play
like G5
and gets very messy
like for example oh
so Queen D3 G5
I want to play Queen G6 maybe I take
first
so that gives a pawn I might be losing
B2
the end of things
um
takes
Bishop D6 is interesting
took me a while to spot that move
there's rage 4g3
couple pawns hanging
very confusing position
[Music]
and be forced on the horizon
that's annoying move
but I can take
the rook's still hanging
hmm
oh my Bishop's getting trapped
no I can take
I
think
and then Bishop P4
it was close call somehow I'm up a pawn
to do here
I didn't know what to do
ah
actually maybe it's okay Ricky too
crazy position
[Music]
yeah I win this Pawn
no
um I'm so sad
I'm so sad
what to do
ah
There Goes My streak too ah it's such a
nice streak
the game though
still top hundred
still many more games to go
there's been a ton of time scrambles
time scrambles this tournament
um yeah of
I'm getting a cardio workout this
tournament
hi Eric less than three oh hi Arab
welcome back
oh I'm playing morality muraldi also
played in Abu Dhabi
Albers are back
um
to this move
it's actually a cool opening idea like
The Bishop's almost getting trapped but
not quite
this was Bishop E8 there
wow
what is this position
funny position
really funny position
[Music]
I like the position
looks Pleasant I'm going to bring my
knight to E4
so A4 B4
um
I don't think I wanna
let's play this uh I don't know
okay I'm gonna say that that was
probably questionable but I don't see
how about Ah that's how black defends
let's double up
okay there's a funny idea
ah opponent saw the funny idea
it's still looking good though
it's so locked up we both have Ollie
Pawns
but White's really tied down to G3
like really tied down
we're gonna have two's coming
and the these things are stuck
yeah we're gonna have two and Bishop G3
oh no my Bishop
someone call an ambulance but not for me
okay that was a really feel good game
I won this game without losing a single
Pawn
and the opening it featured an idea
that
you can get from a different move order
like there's a funny idea after Bishop
G5 and 94 in this position
one of the top engine moves
is H5
with ideas just to expand and trap the
bishop
so that's what I did in the game
a little bit delayed
it worked out really nicely
okay back on track
70th Place
got berserking points too for that game
Oh Thank you Kirk Carson
something with Prime
during a super fun game
oh playing this player yeah we played so
many times before
a good score against this player
do I berserk back don't lie don't
berserk back because
a bun disappeared
ah this line
yeah this one's tricky I need to
okay we'll get some position
F3 first maybe H3 idea F4
five
I'm gonna go full Attack Mode here
and dark stories are very weak
so where's the Breakthrough
there's Bishop H6
I think I believe Bishop oh no Bishop
for Queen C5
if I take Bishop takes
and that looks fine
ah there's a cool idea E5 Queen C5 King
h195
take take
but I think I have to start by taking
and now he found it
that's what the queen can take
trying to make this work
and queen takes I'll play rookie one
seems like there's a good comp here
oh wow
four
Queen
I don't want a queen trade
between H6
hmm
it's still not upon
Bishop D4 may be coming
I had to be a mouse slip
oh no
okay that was a green slip on my heart
still fighting though
now do you want to I win the queen
that's going to be messy finish here
maybe I take with Pawn
Pawn Yeah I've taken with Pawn actually
looks better
wow
okay that was that was an interesting
turnaround I think I was in trouble
somewhere there
okay back on the streak
looking nice
yeah well I'll talk about duck chest
later I know a lot of people are excited
about Chess
gotta get a a healthy dose of normal
chess
um
we are more than halfway through the
tournament
playing Captain Jack Sparrow I'm not
gonna berserk I'm gonna try and show no
mercy
probably need my extra time
to Obama London time
above a London time
I think that's three
I think Knight C6 is fine
takes and takes
yeah this is already a good line for
that I think
I mean Levy walked into this actually
like very similar line against me
so up upon Upon Time
into my C4
Queen E5
now E3
trying to destabilize the setup
also turning E2
oh
Queen E7
now E2
hmm
[Music]
and this looks okay still
this Rook takes Ibiza B6 Queen takes
takes along with the rook in the end
F4 is hanging
so Bishop B6
there's not a five
I wonder if I can play Knight F3 first
also take first
okay this first
it's still tricky
G6 might be coming
oh no I hung a queen
oh no my queen
oh it's so sad
I'm so sad right now
up a little bit of time
good move
okay I resign ah that was unfortunate oh
it's such a good position too what
should I do wrong
yeah this is all I'm sure fine I have
three probably not correct
only move rookie three
uh Rook E3 makes sense
rookie three rookie three Queen F4
takes
I had to follow some Thin Line though
oh what should I do
okay top 80 still
and this is kind of the home stretch
still a lot of games to go
okay
playing with flaw master
yeah this is a fun one because after
Bishop D6
there's a cool move
yeah
so many people evolved for this
this is one of the like the early London
drops I learned so many years ago
and black uh Black's just crumbling here
because of takes I take here if takes I
take on B7 first
guaranteed to win the pawn
yeah with Rook B8
still take on B7
I guess this is maybe one of the better
lines for Bach
I should still be up a pawn in the end
though
um probably just take the queen
and take the bishop
and take the pawn
there's this move too
tying Down The Rook to defending F7
yeah I was looking like how to set up a
castle Fork
it doesn't quite work though
so I'll play B3
yeah I'm up upon but it's actually like
it takes a lot of work to to win this
it takes in Knight T2
I got The Rook to C2
hmm
I want to play A4
A4 Rook B1 takes takes
hmm
not so simple
not sure if I'm even like much better
here
should still be okay
how to make use of my
extra Pawn somehow
and Connect Four
maybe connect five incoming
conduct five
oh it's a draw
it might just be a draw like I don't see
a way to make progress
engine yeah engine maybe he says white
slightly better
but E5
just allows eventually King D5
okay
what to do I got one tournament point
for that
and a pause oh those are [ __ ]
you for the duck variant Discovery today
yeah I do hope to play some duck chess
maybe a little bit later
okay we'll go for this sort of attack
different move order than I'm used to
A6
considering taking with C Pawn
some of these lines
wow
you have to take
uh
uh wait
stop by taking
some initiative hitting the pawn and the
Queen and preparing this
allowing uh maybe it's okay
Queen C7 check
H4 coming
H5
the Knight doesn't have a great Square
or does it
I spoke too soon
okay this is an idea now
also this
oh I miss Maiden one oh I found me in
one okay
okay let's go
68th place
the leader has 96 points wow
okay
uh played this opponent before I'll play
a Stafford
oh King's Gambit
okay this is a [ __ ] beer counter cabbage
this is a dubious line but it's um it's
interesting
yeah Knight C3 is a mistake
because I believe this is considered to
be good for black
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Bishop's attacked
by the battery this check I think is
just harmless
okay
still have to be careful I might play
King h8
and there's Bishop F2 as well
oh yes
oh yes
let's go for this
I just didn't want to deal with the
discovery checks
now I can take Knight G5 H6
there's Queen B7 gets a little bit murky
yeah I thought each six here
is okay
hmm
up a piece
okay
I might as well take a pawn
the bishop is pinned to C2
thank you tree potato
appreciate the gifted Sons
two potatoes grow on trees
no
they're like Roots root vegetables
uh this was a thing
I've um
B4 here
so oh no my Rook first of all
second of all
what's happening can I take on F4
Bishop takes
I'm really taking advantage of that this
bishop is pinned to C2
it was richie7
all right G7 I made into
this is a big threat
Queen's side down to the Rook too
we might see Rook D1
wait oh wow that's so close to me I have
to play this move
I didn't even see that like I almost got
mated
I think it's still okay though
yeah where's my fancy finish
check
and checked here
this looks pretty good hitting this and
this
okay that took some work that was a fun
line though
counter gamma to the king's Abbott
so I'm trying for for top 50.
I think is a reasonable goal
okay sticking with the same
repertoire
so this is another Gambit if Queen B2 I
play E4
instead of this a while ago I talk about
this a little bit in my London course
there's about five night B3 yeah this is
more positional
this looks weird but generally the G3
square is a little bit better for the
knights
um I'm not being aggressive
yeah generally when the opponent plays
like this on the Flink
it's best to respond in the center
But It's Tricky
maybe this is fine I'll play Bishop G3
like I'm expecting 94. Bishop G3 and
after it takes takes the king is
actually really safe
on H2
remember Anish giri talking about
he had some video where he talks about
like the structure
oh
okay maybe this isn't so good it's only
good when they take
any
any sorts of counter play
no this is actually really bad
you know this move
try and muddy the waters
so if takes takes I hit the rook and
prepare G3
sign I take
first take the knights
I'm gonna be down upon
life or some nitrade
idea Queen B3
I promise that each Pawn is coming down
I can't really stop it
F4 E4
complete E4
that's a pawn sack
it's kind of a desperate measure but the
idea Rook D1
so I'm opening up the rank too
Queen E3
so I'm down two pawns now
I have E5
sort of this idea of this and then Rook
D6
there's Queen H6 but
maybe it's okay
probably don't mind the queen trade
A5 is a bit loose
there's this idea
play this
it's a little bit terrifying
I might have to force Perpetual soon
[Music]
I'm probably gonna have to force
perpetual
it takes G2 I think it's just a draw
like we're both very close to getting
muted
this is a draw
[Music]
okay
okay a peaceful end uh
have a very intense battle
oh man
okay got a couple of terminal points for
that
41 points total
I was probably in trouble at some point
like out of the middle game
but it was kind of some cool counter
play there
got a G3 line
D4
play my usual
I'd see three well this is opening
a different opening than
I'm used to
okay a lot of Trades
C5 or d8
don't mind the queen trade
wow
I'm hitting the b-pawn
looks like I'm winning a pawn here
it's a nice idea to play 93 after B5
okay here I just take ah interesting
I'm very clever
that's still tricky
oops wasn't offended
not my time too
foreign
I'm so sad
oh it's a spike check
for a moment I thought like I've had
made in one but Ah that's unfortunate
I got dirty Flags
yeah I mean I was like doing well the
whole game but
what to do
okay gotta calm down play a little bit
quicker
okay let me try to get back on a streak
playing an opponents who I played before
going back to Sicilian
Queen E2
yeah generally against B3
I just play B6
my D5 is a playable move
okay we'll make things a little bit
spicy here
it's tempting to play
Queen F4
just an orifice and White's position
Bishop C1 Queen E5
now a bit of D4 there's F4 Queen
somewhere
Queen
it's not easy for a white to Castle
and queen is a little bit precariously
placed
wow gaussian queenside
I guess it was easy for white to Castle
so I can check and play B5
Knight's pins are the B2 Square
that's a move
I think I have to play E5 here
it gives away a D5
but I'm ready to take and put the Rook
on the B file
Bishop almost a twitch baby
hey keep it up choco Roku
happy eight months
um
if I take
okay I'll bring the knight in
wow
so if I take the knights
a taken Castle
I can still legally Castle both ways
the king seems safe and this square is
really nice for me
White's Off with this kind of useless
Bishop
you're ready to go for Rook C8
yeah it's good night versus bad Bishop
yeah Queen F2 is met with uh takes and
then takes and then Fork
going for A4
Queen B2
let's avoid the queen trade oh wait a
minute
the A3 would trap the queen
wow
ah maybe I can take first
The Rook takes I take in Fork Queen has
to take
and now Queen B4
well my Queen's not getting trapped
A4 is idea
epon is forever backwards
Queen C5
I think I'm okay losing this Pawn
or am I
hook here
time's not great
McQueen
check meeting the king okay
ended kind of abruptly there I'll take
it
oh you just finished commentating your
college Testament oh that's cool
any twitch commentating advice for
beginners
um
most importantly is that you enjoy it
so try and make it fun sometimes people
prefer to do it solo sometimes it's nice
to have a co-commentator
um
yeah the way to get better is to just be
consistent
so
like when I first started streaming and
even doing commentary
I was
I was uncomfortable it took a lot of
hours to find some comfort
and find some Rhythm it could also help
to like re-watch your commentary
and see what areas you can improve in
yeah this is a line
I think E3
maybe D5 was a main move
there's some funny idea to take I don't
think it works though
okay so we have a reverse benoni
and this is one big trade
Knight B6 good move
yeah to move back
I'm sure black is very happy with this
position
[Music]
ah my business upset I should have
played Bishop H2
oh what to do
C4
you see three
just live with uh shattered tone
structure
that's really not pleasant
[Music]
um
like I'm not down material that the
position is just so bad
I'm talking the night back
down about a minute
nice move
yeah the pawn was overworked there
oh
very fancy
it's completely losing
I should probably resign soon
I'll keep playing though
let me try and lose the rest of my pawns
and then
attempt this stalemate thing
ah okay I love the queen trade what to
do
gotta played that game
yeah next time maybe I should play D5
earlier in the opening
thank you you Sabo first time RhymeZone
okay
actually I haven't lost
more than one game in a row this
tournament
I'll try and keep it that way
let me try and win
some games in a row
this is already a pleasant opening
Queen takes her Pawn takes
apontex
now each four coming
it was a cool position
[Music]
this Pawn feels like a duck
it was just in the way of box
development
uh where's my where's my cool line Queen
D4
I want to play Knight G6
oh no my queen
okay triple Fork
oh no my Bishop
oh no my opponents okay
that was a nice game
nice quick berserk win
okay I've been hovering in the 60s
haven't been in top 50 yet
it'll take some uh yeah some win streak
to get there
okay let's play this fun gamut line c6s
line
that's not super well known yet
but it has been rising in popularity
yeah the idea I sacked upon but the idea
is to kick around this night
H5 this is still some Theory
E3 is most played
more gambits please oh the first
tournament I played the stream every
game was a Gambit
the episode B5 so what's the line here I
think H3 first
and queen F6
hey this
I don't fully remember
after this game I can check the theory
there is some game
uh samian versus ilionic from like a
year ago
that featured a very similar line like
they had the same position after Bishop
B5
I remember some idea like the queen is
actually a little bit misplaced on A4
because when A6 comes it's gonna be a
Target eventually
I'm still down the pond but
yeah the event white trades off the
light squared Bishop the Nike squares
are very weak
got my Alpha zero Pawn
it's Bishop is slow to develop
maybe this idea too
some juicy squares
wow
so allowing some night jump
I'm tempted to play this first
the Knight takes Knight B4 Queen B3
Bishop E6
there's one calculation
40 months all top engines say continuing
to sub to Eric is the best move for your
chest yeah follow the top engine move
I won't report You for Cheating
like before
the pawn was attacked so I move it
I'm also cutting off the defense of the
queen as
I might want to take soon
I go for G5
like a g
h
Queen A5
it should be six
E4 is coming
foreign
preventing E4
oh it's such a funny position
I want to play G4 and clamp down
E4 is still coming though
unless I play this in G4
very confusing position
[Music]
maybe I'll play Queen A5 and uh that
allows me F6
F4
I'm just leaving my king in the center
oh like Queen traps
Queen B8
take take
I have to play Queen
it's not pleasant
queen bee it is
delayed bong Hound
oh no my king
how bad is this
it looks really bad
95
and then King F6
oh
uh
D4 is coming
[Music]
king of Fades Knight F7 idea
barely holding on
foreign
terrifying
how am I not dead yet
thank you
I'm so grateful to be alive
oh yes my queen
okay
oh wow that was scary I was getting
smashed by Godzilla
but I squirmed my way away
okay 66th
approaching 50 tournament points
playing r1064 I'll build her back
transposing into the sign
yeah maybe I should have played E4
earlier
into B3
B3
I'd rather my pawns be on light squares
oh I'd rather not plunder to
good move
okay this is a scary decision
okay maybe maybe D5 coming soon
some initiative
oh I didn't see that
doing this and this
Ah that's not a threat though
okay have this
preventing this
wow I forgot the Rook was hanging
okay I'm gonna play C4
door my queen
just blind to that
oh no my Rook
oh no blocks Queens
okay I resign
uh
that was rough
made lots of mistakes that game
There Goes My streak
okay what to do
foreign
[Music]
reasonable decision to berserk
uh Stafford Gambit declined
I had a similar line earlier
that's already a pleasant position
[Music]
so D4 is hanging
threading this
yeah
this Arrow didn't make sense but these
arrows make sense
okay 13 move win
the Stafford declined
can't complain
okay top 16.
top 50 is still within range
approaching the final half hour
okay just for your cheer okay no
Halloween I would have gone for it if
opponent played E5
uh no Halloween gamuts yet
I mean they have the whole month to
get some Halloween gambits
I had this position earlier too
um it's a line
five possible
this might be questionable but it's
interesting
maybe I could have taken I should have
taken
so if not here I'm actually tempted to
play Bishop D3
and pawn D3 also playable
oh wow
okay so a bit of C5
Block's gonna win back the pawn
or will they
yeah those Pawn's hanging
Queen G4
um
that's kind of annoying
for each three
yeah losing the pawn
okay D5
how do you tell Jason
[Music]
okay now D5 the problem for black is
this pawns tied down to the night
this Pawn can't be taken
how D6
wow
oh no
I was just blind to that
was box one idea too I'm gonna have to
take
it's not over though
maybe bishop E6
this is actually crazy position
oh no
this doesn't work at all
I'm getting nated
oh
okay
yeah Rook C1 that's amazed
I guess it's just lost
I should have been aware
oh maybe I'm just worse
yeah I thought like I'm pushing for more
but
after Queen C5 I guess I just played
into Black's idea
that was rough
okay
it's been a very non-3k tournament for
me been alternating wins and losses
French defense there's other times I
take opening requests
uh but sure I'll play I'll play E6 just
for you you uh you requested it at the
right time but it's not quite a French
I guess if you're a French defense
player this still might be an opening in
your repertoire
let's start with H6
and play a bit more aggressively here
hmm
going for this idea
happy October any chance you could play
a Brooklyn oh I already did actually
I played it earlier it was crazy game
earlier too
uh feel free to go back watch the VOD or
watch the Future YouTube video
okay this is a structure I'm
very very much used to
might be threatening this
also might not be take six takes
yeah like I want to do it but
that's no good
Queen z7
avoiding the queen trade ready to play
Knight E4
to hit the queen
interesting
okay ideas to maneuver to D6
this part is kind of lonely but
you can't really be attacked
hmm
yeah five might be an idea
uh Knights and I see five maybe coming
restricting Knight E5
it was almost a free Pawn but not quite
zigzagging the bishop
to a new home
this might be an idea never mind
F5 was probably the eventual idea
but always have to be wary of 95.
oh nights are interesting um
they're kind of like Christmas
decorations
they look pretty but are they doing
anything
foreign
for this
or maybe other Halloween decorations
they look scary
but are they actually like a threat to
me
can decorations be pretty and scary
some ideas to uh maneuver to the H file
okay that's a good sign
not sure if I'm crashing through
always repeat a couple times but never
three times
and
what's the best way to do this
foreign
okay a little bit more repeating
oh E4 maybe I should not have
gone for this
okay let's move back
uh
hitting B3
[Music]
those final moves felt like Pac-Man I
just keep eating the food
okay
that was an intense game
the the winning and losing streak
continues
alternating a lot
thank you Murray something with Prime
berserk
lost for this opponent before
try and get revenge
on the sign
foreign
[Music]
there's takes
the bishop
I trade the bishop
take some Queen D3
these poems are a bit saturated
that's what I needed
and those defend each other thankfully
in the end
both nights were attacked
yeah I have enough counter play
oh tricky
it's not so simple
this first
ah
how to do this
I wasn't sure what to do there
oh no I have to bail out for a draw
oh I was winning
okay we'll draw
okay what to do
and quick game
almost top 60.
about 20 minutes left
okay who's the person that wanted a
French French defense
confused Mom I hope you're satisfied
uh I'll play a Fort Knox how about
the Fort Knox is Bishop D7 Bishop Z6
I think eventually taken uh Pawn C6
when Jeffrey Zhang went through a phase
of playing this
he actually played this against me in a
tournament
we got a very similar position
that's a very positional line
and playing against uh the Pawns
a little bit less space but still
relatively solid
B5 is interesting
trying to get the D the D5 Square
C5 Queen C7
yeah it's maybe still a little bit worse
for black
and 96 is coming
I want to play 98.
I have five coming
wow
that was a big trainer
I want to draw
um
one more move one more move
because there there is some chance that
light goes wrong
now this is just a draw
you have to make sure I click the right
button
okay
okay a berserk draw
that was worse out of the like middle
game
I was happy with the opening though
that Fort Knox was simple simple opening
to play if you play the French and you
don't want to learn like the super main
lines
I'll play Owen's defense
okay maybe just for Pablo if I'm black
again we'll see
Owens defense is B6
okay we'll play London first
okay one of these
Knight C6
going full aggression here ah Bishop G4
still playable I'm gonna be down the
exchange
oh
the thing is that Rooks aren't so useful
just yet
in such a position
[Music]
so I can block the C file
oh that's a me threat
probably A3 coming soon
I have this first
okay targeting F7
because I need to play this but then
Queen F6
defending the pawn
I gotta move a bit more quickly here
[Music]
um
foreign
it's going to be a time scramble I mean
this is kind of what I signed up for
C3
trying to hold on here
oh good move
there we go
I missed a free Bishop somewhere it's
okay though
okay
oh it wasn't easy routine is left
55th Place trying to approach top 50.
okay
haven't lost a game in a while actually
white again London again
this is generally a pleasant line
that's generally very pleasant
there isn't an H5 here
Bishop D6 is fine
a funny Pawn structure
still have all eight Pawns
okay this is coming
hmm
thank you
the the diamond's about to oh no my
diamond
I just lose upon I think I just lost a
pawn
really
forget about
it's just winning looks really close to
winning
maybe not quite though
hmm
wow I'm just in time I didn't calculate
that fully I was just hoping it would be
in time and now it takes and takes and
it's winning
okay
foreign
okay double berserk win after a couple
draws
did I miss upon Fork
maybe at some point G4 but
I think there was counter play in some
cases
okay
been getting this a lot today
had a similar line my first game a few
other games too
um
how to do this
maybe this is
playable
[Music]
yeah so now I have the outside passer
wow
let's start with this
I have to be really careful here
Queen d8
I don't think if an A6 works
oh
oh wait that doesn't work da I have B5
uh losing upon
not looking good
wait
oh for some reason I thought it was
White's move I guess I didn't see F3
played oops
I was losing that anyway white played a
good game
yeah Queen side got weak
okay
playing Grand Master Red King I have a
better score against
okay
uh is this opening
foreign
no
Queen D7
oh it's a line
we played some Theory
looks okay now
hitting C2
nice restricted by the bishop
how is white not losing ah there we go
oh what to do C5
foreign
wow okay I'm losing the final position
but
oh yeah Queen G7 was not missed because
the White Queen was pinned
um I would go back and show it but uh
there's no time to waste
okay
maybe time for one more game yay top 50
top 50. can I keep it though
a lot of players on my tail
oh playing team of a very strong player
probably knocking the berserk so
this game might not count for the
tournament
I kind of need to win the
finish top 50 I think
given the standings
I'll play London Mainline
I Bishop E7 Bishop D3
[Music]
wait what's the line here
was up
wait I'm trying to remember the line
let me take some Bishop H4
prepared this for Spiller a while ago
oh no
uh actually it's okay I think Queen's
side down to the night
yeah this is okay
E4 is coming
I want to play E5 at some point
foreign
95
.
tonight's almost trapped
that's a good sign
Knight B4 was a threat there
okay some attacking ideas
queen wants to come to F4
Knight wants to come here in here
okay threatening both Pawns
you pawns pin to the queen also
threading a fork
I do 95
.
foreign
the knights
ah determines up I mean
everything's hanging for black here
we're gonna see
what are we gonna see The Bishop's
hanging lights hanging there's also some
funny ideas of like checkmating or um
playing Knight G5 and winning a queen
I take with Chuck
wait oh I'm almost blundered meat
uh uh that's a meat threat wow Doc's
forking everything
I think I have to take the Knight oh no
my queen
but this is winning now
I was just not blunder meat
uh
even Rook D2 wait Rook d2's blundering
let's play this
up the tempo here
foreign
to play with a little time
okay
nice finish to the tournament
beating a strong GM
yeah T-Mobile is um
I don't know what his feet is but uh I'm
definitely over 2600 I believe
back to tournaments 52nd Place
not quite top 50 but
overall
um
die gain rating
was my reading just start the day
hey I gained four points
over the course of 52 Blitz Games
at this rate I'll be 2700
and several hundred more games
okay
oh I edged out King's Crusher
we finished with the same score but I
guess my tie breaks were
slightly better
I think it's likely I'll put this whole
term on YouTube